nacho
[Musique]
oui ce qu'ils ont et continuent de
buback ministre a mis en garde à vue
sauf si on est sous la neige typiquement
on a une chance de survivre ca de 90 %
dont les premiers quinze minutes et les
prochains 15 minutes
ça diminue de 50 % ça passe à 45 etc
c'est lui fournit des journées tout
drugs
[Musique]
cette fois là c'était les puits d'armes
qu'on appelle j'avais tomber la tête par
an bol le bois des prix en deux armes
salah cumul sur moi la neige puis le
j'étouffe je l'aimerais à reprendre mon
souffle puis je suis même je peux même
pas crier pour des chercheurs puis
j'entends les gens autour de moi en
euphorie qui sont celles qui il sa main
poche il a pas ce que c'est les armes
qui sont sont proches
et quand ça m'est arrivé avec ma moto
neige c'était aussi dans un flux d'armes
j'avais le poids de la moto neige qui
était tombée par de ce mois alors tu
essaies de respirer cuites les poumons
peuvent même pas monté j'ai le masque
j'ai mon classe de motoneige qui est
comme pauvres comme ça alors je peux
même pas essayé j'étais vraiment coincé
je pense à ma famille je me dis oh mon
dieu comment qui vont l'apprendre je
pense à mon homme
et puis là j'entends le bruit de la
motoneige de match mais je parle de ce
que j'ai comme des émotions parce que
c'est le bruit de la motoneige kirghize
quand je vais tour est joué qu'avec
[Musique]
m
souvent des gens dans mon métier qui
abandonnent à partir d'un certain moment
parce que ils ont trop vu où ils
entreprennent où ils sont trop de
coupures culpabilité à partir de là si
on n'était pas là bas personne derrière
nous secours et sauvetage en montagne
c'est ce qu' on appelle quand
l'ambulancier ne peut pas venir quand le
pompier ne peut pas venir il ya plus
personne donc si nous on n'est pas là
bas il ya personne c'est ça qu'il faut
continuer à avoir du plaisir c'est pour
ça que j'habite ici c'est pour être dans
les montagnes puis jamais je dois
m'arrêter d'être dans les montagnes
on fait ce qu'on aime ce qui nous tient
en vie m'a même temps c'est le paradoxe
ça peut être quelque chose d'aussi qui
nous enlève la vie
oh
[Musique]
depuis que j'ai eu ces deux ces deux
moments de voir ma vie peut être pris
comme ça puis c'est ça c'est la fin j'y
pense toujours
ça fait que je pense oui
[Musique]